Abby came and shaking her head no, but I love droughts. Difference of opinion.
Thank you. We will now transition from parks and recreation
to Houston Police department.
At this time, I would welcome Chief
Fender and Miss Rhonda. Smith, the CFO of Houston Police
Department, along with Chief Satterwhite.
Chief Slinkert. And I thought I saw Chief Jones as well.
So good to see everybody.
And of course, Ms. Rhonda Smith, the CFO. Chief, I saw
you in DC. You look good. How was that plane trip?
Oh, you're a smart man. Yeah.
Good to see you.
I just want to thank each and every
council member for such support. It means
a lot having the opportunity to talk to chiefs all around the nation and
to have the support from the Horseshoe. It means a lot,
but we'll jump right into it.
Chief Troy Finner. And on behalf of the Houston Police Department,
I appreciate the opportunity to submit the HPD's
proposed budget budget for FY 2023.
Let me first say how proud I am to be the
police chief in this great city with this great department.
The benefit of the burian audience. HPD is the
largest agency in the state of Texas, fourth largest in the
nation. We have over I'm sorry, the fifth
largest in the nation. We have over 6100,
both classified and civilian employees.
Before moving forward, I'd like to acknowledge the men and women of the Houston
Police Department, but especially the executive staff and the budget
and finance staff who has worked so diligently to prepare
this presentation. This year began and
has been very challenging for us, as around
the nation, we lost some of our own family members.
But in Houston and Harris County,
there was a total of six. Now, last week,
seven line of duty deaths. We also faced
the challenge of increasing
crime. At the beginning of the year, especially,
my top priority is to address those.
The trends of increasing crime was to reduce
the violent crime, enhance technology, and also
improve the staffing. Just want to say the
One Safe Houston initiative has been successful. We've been
doing an excellent job looking at the numbers. Every week those
numbers have been going down, and we've seen a reduction in
violent crime on a weekly basis. So, again, I want to thank
the mayor, I want to thank City Council for the additional
opera rescue funding and fighting crime and reducing
some of that crime and improving the quality of life.
I want to hit on one stat before
we move forward. In January,
as compared to the previous year, our homicide numbers
were over 70%. Today it's 7%.
And that is a direct result of
good policing, but also everybody
working together, our citizens and the criminal justice system
coming together. Technology.
We have secured the following major technology milestones.
Body warrant camera upgrades will allow us to
purchase the next well, 300 I'm sorry,
3500 next generation body worn cameras.
The HPD data center locate relocation.
We completely moved the HPD primary data center
to a shared space within the city data center.
We've moved over 300 servers.
We've implemented Shot spotters not only in the Southeast,
but also in the North Division. Now,
I'm sorry, our RMS system, we're in a quiet period,
but we have an RFP out.
That's all I'm going to say about that. But it will assist
us in our fight of violent crime.
We want to make our real time crime center a true strategic
decision support system. The expansion
of automated license plate readers in
high crime areas and also cameras. So we're looking,
and I want to thank certain council members for
funding that. It's something that we want
to move around the city, but it's not just the
responsibility of the city and taxpayers. We want to get
everybody on board on that.
We also, in terms of staffing, we have
to continue to fund the five academy
classes each year.
Also want to thank council for working on city
audience, for the Cadillac converter audience, the noise audits
audits. And also the exterior
security video camera audit audits.
And also the county for passing the 10%
bond for defendants charged with violent crime.
The presentation will begin with an overview of organizational structure.
For the sake of time, I will move through these slides quickly and answer any
questions at the end. Next slide.
This slide shows a current organization structure.
Next slide.
This slide is basically the addition of the executive
assistant Chief I'm sorry, the Executive chief, chief Slinker,
which we added that new position at the beginning of my administration.
Next slide. This is
the office of the police, of the Chief of Police.
Everything that's up under my command. Next slide.
This slide, it looks at investigations and special operations.
It's under Chief Jones.
And the next slide is patrol operations on the chief satellite.
Next slide, please. This is a special fund.
In addition to our general funds, our organization
includes operations and special funds.
These are funds that are restricted. The money is
restricted for restricted use. I meant to say Ms. Smith will
go into further detail here just shortly.
Next slide. Want to look at the
breakdown of gender of our agency. The significant
thing about this slide is for cities of
over 1 million in population I'm
sorry, we move it. One more slide. One more.
Thank you.
For cities over 1 million in population.
And the police departments have 17%
female. HPD is also at 17%.
For the civilian, that's for classified. For the civilians,
we're at 68% as compared to the national average
of 66%.
HPD is one of the most diverse law enforcement agencies in
the nation. We're a majority I'm sorry. Next slide. Go to it.
HPD is one of the most diverse agencies
in the nation. We are a majority minority police department
with 78.9% of the
civilians are minority, 60.9% of classified.
A closer breakdown of it looking at the classified side,
39% Caucasian,
31% Hispanic or Latino,
21% African American and
8% Asian. For the civilian workforce,
we have 45% African American,
21% White, 25% Latino
Hispanic and then 8% Asian.
The department programming. I always like to state our mission statement.
Mission statement is to hang the quality of life in the
city of Houston by working cooperatively
with the public within the framework work of the US constitution
to enforce laws, preserve the peace,
reduce fear, and provide a safe environment.
Next slide.
Reducing violent crime is one of the mayor's highest
priorities, and we have made great strides in accomplishing
the goal. Despite financial challenges and staffing,
some of the core duties prevent
crime, respond to calls for service, conduct investigations,
arrest individuals suspected of committing crimes,
coordinate with Homeland Security activities, protect lives and
property during mass gathering and special events, and also enforcing traffic.
Next slide.
Department program continues statutory requirements of
delivery of services. The Texas Code of Criminal Procedure
and the city ordinance. Chapter 34, article two, defines the
duties of the Houston Police Department.
Recently, our team
published a five year strategic plan listing five
key organizational priorities. One was
public safety. Building community trust was two.
Three was professional development. Four was Operational
Excellence and five was productivity.
This budget proposal funding request for key
initiatives discussed in this plan, which are first
ePROs and that is employment programs
for retired officers.
42 individuals will come back as retired officers
and it will give us immediate assistance in investigations
and other administrative duties. Five cadet classes
budgeted for 75 per class. A gun
intelligence center. We're working with Atl to implement
a robust gun intelligence center. And also cell
phones. Continued cell phones for each classified
officer previously. This is funded by the
Cares Act. I would like
to now ask Ms. Smith, our Chief Financial
Officer, to provide an overview of the 2023
proposed budget. Thank you.
Thank you, Chief. Good morning everyone.
My name is Rhonda. Smith, as the chief has said.
And I am the deputy director for the Houston Police Department.
And I echo Chief Sinner's
sentiment in terms of working with such a great crew.
And so I want to take just a minute point of privilege to talk about
the Office of Budget and Finance who've been working tirelessly throughout
the year and particularly now for the budget presentation.
So I'm going to ask them just to stand so I can acknowledge them.
So we're always behind the scenes, so they are a little shy,
but thank you. So as we move forward, this first
slide is the revenue by fund. First, I'd like to just say that
the police department operates under six funds.
The primary fund is the general fund, which makes up about 97%
of our operations. The other funds are special funds. And so each
fund has a revenue component. And this is what you see here on this
slide. So for the first item, general fund and I'll
be speaking from the column that's titled Fiscal Year 23 proposed Budget
for the General Fund. The proposed revenue
anticipated is $43.5 million.
Now, it's revenue, but it's actually a reimbursement.
84% of that is the reimbursement that we receive from
the airport systems. So we provide those services for intercontinental
hobby and the Ellington field.
The next item is our police special services
fund. This is a collection of special funds for restricted
use. For example, all of the training that we do that is
provided by the state flows through this fund,
reimbursement for what's called MoUs, or Memorandum of
Understanding, which we have with other agencies,
flow through this fund and funding for our combat
against human trafficking, as well as cost recovery services
and special funds and special events.
We anticipate that that budget would be 7.9 million.
And our next item, our special fund is auto dealers.
And for revenue for that one, we are anticipating 8.5
budgeted for the auto dealers. And of course, with auto
dealers, it's a standalone fund. And this fund
is responsible for regulating automotive businesses,
auto salespersons, storage lots, and towing industry. So the
revenue we receive primarily is coming from fees that we charge
in servicing that process. Our next
item is child safety fund. And that's clearly just a flow through.
Just for by way of background, in 1991,
the state legislature required that any population over 850,000
should fund it. And we fund it through assessing certain
fees on municipal fines. And so what
we get, we pass back through. And if we don't get
enough, then there's no money else, no other
way to get the funding. And so that's what that child safety
fund is. And of course, asset forfeiture. So under
asset forfeiture. The one thing I'll say,
and I know my stuff is looking at me because we cannot budget
for asset forfeiture because it's on a
case by case basis other than the state allows us to do some budgeting.
But I will say that typically right now, we're budgeting $2 million,
which is, if you look in the history, it's a little lower than anticipated.
But what has happened is that we are taking
the same impact everyone else is with COVID and the court systems,
because in order to receive these funds, it has to flow through the
court system. So we're hoping that in time
that we will be back on chart. And lastly
is the Forensic Transition fund. And that Forensic Transition Fund
that shows 373,000,000 is really just a flow through
because back in 2014, I believe we
transitioned the operations of the Forensic Fund to the local
government corporation. But we kept the funding,
we kept the actual individuals that were associated
with HPD in our funding.
So we received reimbursement. So the good news is
it's doing what it's supposed to. It was a transition. It started with
probably more than 20. Now we only have three staff left.
So we anticipate over the next several years that that will move down.
So what we have in total is $65 million
for revenue. Next slide, please.
So this slide just highlights some of the reasons why
there's a difference from year to year and the comparison is
with the estimated revenue compared to the budget. So for General Fund
we're showing a $1.4 million increase. As I
mentioned before, 84% of the General Fund revenue has to
do with our services to the police, of services to the
airport system. So of course a lot of the increase has to do with the
contractual obligations. In reference to the 4% increase
for police and the 3% for civilian.
The one thing I will highlight that the one new add
on is seven positions anticipated
for the last five months of the fiscal year that have to do with the
integrated coordination center which is being created by the airport
system and they have requested our participation in that,
but of course they will be reimbursing us for it. So I'm going to
skip to auto dealers and you'll see a small decrease. But really
that's just because fiscal year 22 we saw uptick
in the increase of selling cars that have been stored
and the actual funding for that.
So we tend to budget pretty conservatively. So we've
gone back to what we typically would see
during a year. And the last item that I
will include is the forensic transition. But I've already explained that one
why that's going down, so next slide please.
So this is the expenditure by fund. So for General Fund,
the proposed budget is $988,000,000
or a difference of 33 million.
And I will explain that a little bit later
on and go into a little bit more detail. In terms of the general
budget for police special Fund, we have a
budget of $10.9 million and most of that is personnel.
But we do also have some increases because of technology
increase, technology enhancements that we are anticipating this fiscal
year.
The only other thing that I will focus on is asset forfeiture,
but I think I've kind of mentioned that before and why that number
appears to be going up, but we didn't spend as much last year,
but we do anticipate spending a little bit more this year. Thank you.
Next slide please. This is the expenditure highlights
which shows the difference. As I mentioned with General Fund there's a $33 million
difference which I'll go in into the next slide and
I believe I've already explained the differences in the others. So I'll
move forward with the next slide please.
So this is the slide that explains
how we came up to the 988,000,000.
If you recall, last year we had a budget adopted of 955,000,000 and
throughout the year there are adjustments to the budget. For example,
there are adjustments in the restricted funds that are shared
funds that we are provided that number from the
administration. And then we of course we have the adjustment for
the 3% increase for the Hope budget is
what I'd like to refer to as the three three three that we're all very
ecstatic to see happen. And then we
had a decrease in our health benefit. So that's
primarily because we had a lot of more attrition than anticipated.
So the budget was adjusted to reflect that decrease
for health benefits. Then of course we have the Council
council support monies that we've received about $129,000 and
then that gets you and, and of course I can't, I would be remiss if
I didn't add on that. We added the
gunshot detection with the shot spotter and
those are two locations at 350 each. So that's the 700,000.
So that gets us down to what we refer to as the current budget.
And the current budget is just the adopted plus any adjustments we've made during the
year. And from there we get down to how we
came to the current budget, to the fiscal year budget.
And this pretty much shows you every item that has
been adjusted. A lot of it has to do with the Hope and
the contract with the police union HPU in
terms of the increases, the 4% and the 3%. And of course we had
an increase in the health care also.
So I'm not going to go through each one. I wanted to just highlight those
items that may bring up some question if you look
about halfway down there's, the Cadet
adjustment. So last year we had anticipated six classes,
but we now know that filling up the five classes is our priority.
So we readjusted that down to five classes versus
six classes. And then the
last several items here, it's called approved PBJs and
those are requests that we've made to adjust our budget. And I'm happy to
say that we had four this year. One had to do with the body worn
cameras, which was approved this last fiscal year. And this
1.8 represents the storage cost
for the body worn cameras. And of course,
the Chief mentioned the ePRO program also.
Next slide, please.
So this slide represents the
balance between personnel cost and non personnel costs.
So interesting enough, we have 988,000,091%
of that pertains to personnel cost. Last year was about 92,
93%. And you may ask what's happened?
Well, we've got the ePROs program and we also have
another program, I can't remember the name, but the other
program which actually has added to the other
side of it. So now it's 91%. So it's going in
the right direction. Next slide, please.
So I'm going to move through these pretty quickly because if you see with the
special funds, it's mostly 50 50, mostly personnel
and non personnel, it's about 50 50. So with
the Police special fund it is 52% for personnel and
48% for non personnel and special
funds. A lot of the personnel has to do with overtime.
There are some staff, but it's primarily overtime cost
that we receive fund reimbursement for.
Next slide please. So this is asset forfeiture.
It's the same case as 50 50 just about and
that's personnel versus non personnel. So next slide
please. And this is the auto dealers.
The same with this one in terms of personnel
versus non personnel. Next slide please.
So we've put these two on the same slide. The first one is a
child safety and of course that's strictly a flow through. So it's 100%
or almost 100% flow through for
services and for the forensic, it's 100%
personnel. Next slide, please.
So this gives you a historical factor in terms of how
we have fared in comparison with what we've spent
versus our adopted budget. And as you can see that
we typically come on budget. We spend a lot of time making
sure that we stay within our budget. We understand the budgets are
tight and we are fiscally responsible and we want to make
sure that we stand here. So this actual presentation
shows that in a graphical manner. Next slide.
So the next few slides you'll see that the adopted budget is
much more than the expenditures. A lot of times with the special funds,
if we do not have enough time to spend the money,
it's just rolled over to the next fiscal year and that's happened in
the first five years of 2019 through 2023.
Next slide please. The same with asset forfeiture you'll see that
same trend, but we are working to make sure
that the revenue and the adopted budget and the
expenditures are in line,
but there are some times when we run out of time.
Next slide, please. And this is the
auto dealers, which is typically on target.
Next slide, please. And of course it's the child safety
which is a smaller funds.
Next slide. So with that, I'm going to pass it
back over to Chief if he'd like to close us out.
Just again, thanks for the support of
our council members and the citizens as well. But we really wanted
to kind of move through quickly because I wanted to save time for
questions and answers.
Thanks again, Ms. Jones. And Chief Finner.
It's not every day that we have the opportunity to have you
and your command staff in front of us. So again, I'd like to recognize Chief
Slinkert, chief Jones and Chief Satellite, and also
Ray Hunt and Doug Griffin with HPOU who are
valuable partners not only to the police department but to the city council as
well. And also Mr. Peter Stout with the
CEO of the Houston Forensic Science Lab. Our first question
comes from council member Abby Cayman.
Thank you, Mayor Pro TEM. And I have a list of questions, so just
go ahead and put me back in queue. Chief, first off, thank you
so much for your leadership and to the entire team all the
way on down to each division as we
continue to face not only the
surgeon violent crime following the pandemic locally. But could
you share what you're seeing? I know you were just in DC,
what that trip was about and what we're seeing nationally
and how what we are doing is either working or not
working. Thank you for asking. It was a good trip
for not only me, but for the mayor and for our city
and visiting with the President, the Rescue
Act, he pledged to continue
to fund us, and that was a huge thing.
But the meeting, first of all, I just want to say honor
to those men and women who paid the ultimate sacrifice
during that weekend of memorial. But when
you're talking to other chiefs from around the nation, you understand
that everybody has the same problems, with one
exception. Nobody has the backlog problem that we have here in
Houston, Harris County. Absolutely nobody. And in
our conversations, they were amazed. But they're dealing with
some of the same other issues, the gun violence,
letting individuals out of jail when
they're repeating time and time, violent crime.
So that's the challenge. But also recruiting
and just hearing some of the things that they're doing. And I told
the mayor that I think I'll meet this Thursday. I want to talk to him
about some of the recruiting initiatives
that they are putting in place and also probably
using as more funding comes in,
using some of that for some incentives for individuals
coming in to the academy or actually recruiting them.
Mentioned recruitment. There's been
conversations and questions about cadet classes. And I know you mentioned
in this budget there's five, is that correct? And could you
clarify, though, because we oftentimes talk about cadet classes,
but we also are dealing with retention issues. So can you share
with us where that brings us in terms of HPD?
Yes, staffing, the recruiting,
we can always improve. But the biggest problem right now
is the Attrition Rate We're Agent Agency and
a lot of these individuals who are leaving when they get 35, 30 years,
it's hard to keep them when they're ready to go. So as we
put cadets in the class on the back end, people are retiring.
So that is a huge challenge right
now. So it's very important that
we just don't lose hope and understand and hoping that that
time itself out as some of those retire
and then other cadets come through
our academy and come on out on the streets.
Hopefully on the back end, in a few years, we'll be able to hold on
to a lot more for a longer time.
It's not just that we're adding additional numbers. We'll put you back in queue.
Council Member Sally Alcorn.
Thank you, Chair, and thank you, Chief, for the presentation.
I have a question about investigative and special operations.
I know there was talk about clearance rates and how we were doing better ten
years ago than we were doing now.
And we added, I thought some classifieds
to that division. It looks like we budgeted for more
last year and then hired fewer, and now we're trying to
get more. Can you talk a little bit about yeah, I'm proud to say
that our clearance rate, divisional clearance rate and homicide
is at 80% now. That's great.
When you looked at last year in 2020,
those numbers were down. So we're trending in the right direction.
I want to give credit to the great investigative
work and also the leadership on the investigative side,
chief Jones and some of our other assistant chiefs and the
men and women who are doing just knockout investigations.
But again, people don't give
enough credit to the value of good relationships
with citizens. And you see time and
time again, citizens are stepping up more. And I think that's because
of a better relationship and more trust building
in. So it has to all gel together. But I'm
excited about it, and I just pray that we continue to trend that way.
That's great news. Good to hear. On the property room,
how many classifieds do we have working at the property room?
I'm not sure on that number. Does anybody have a property room?
And if not, we'll get that to you. Okay, that's great. And I'd
like to see, in addition to the clearance rate be put on the performance measures
that you all include in the book, the disposition of
property. I know what we receive in and what goes out.
I think we're way in more. We have way
more in in all categories than than what goes out. And that
ties up a lot of officers. We include that council member Tiffany Thomas.
Thank you, Mayor Pro TEM. Hello, Chief. It's good to see you doing this morning.
I'm well. So two questions. One's an aside from the general fund, I'm pretty clear
about how you're funded, but oftentimes we receive
grant where council approves grant award grant applications rather
to support the department. And I remember there was one item,
particularly that was almost like a community
mobile unit that was the
application was supposed to use to
do some community efforts. When do we receive information
that the award was actually accepted or funded
and that those capital pieces of equipment are actually within our
hands? That mobile brand? I think that got it's.
Chief Johnson. Commander Johnson. We just
put in for a year ago. Yeah. So we'll
get some follow up on that and see what we are, because it's a great
idea. We want to go to our communities
because of staffing. A lot of the storefronts were
closed down. So if we can have a mobile outreach,
I guess I used to call them Winnebagos vehicles,
but we can go directly to the community. Right. Just curious about
the status of that. And then secondly, I think my first year in
office, I took a tour of the forensic center. I was fascinated by it,
just overwhelmed with the amount of work that they do.
If I understand this, this is a decrease in their budget. Is this
the variance? Is that a variance? So for what we
have, it's just the number of individuals that transition over from
the city to the forensics. So it's just kind of like a holding
pattern because that was what was agreed upon in order to
keep them with the benefits of the sure. So then this
leads to my question in terms of making sure your officers
on the ground are doing yeoman's work around with the homicide rate.
Everyone's doing their part. That's the asset.
We've asked the community what type of funding would they need in order to
make sure that evidence is not backlog? All of that data collection so
they can keep in track with the goals that we're setting in the city.
We have to stay in communication with our forensic
center as we make more arrests.
There is more of a demand on them, and we need to make sure that
we're meeting that demand. So we've been
in communication, and I'm sure they're going to be in communication
with the mayor to make sure they get what
they need. Sure. Wonderful. So you're not saying we need to play the
mega millions in order to get this funded? Because maybe we need to play some.
I think that there should be some direct conversations
on need and we need to work
together as a team. And the mayor has been just stand up
with that, including the council. When any of us
pertaining to safety of our city needs something and we
present it to everybody has been very fair, and I want us
to keep doing that with all, not only HPD,
but with all departments in the city. Vice Mayor
Pro TEM martha Castex Tatum. Thank you, Chair. Chief Finner, thank you for
the presentation. Ms. Smith, thank you for always being so very thorough.
I wanted to talk a little bit about ShotSpotter.
We had almost a unanimous council vote on the support of ShotSpotter.
Our residents are clamoring for ShotSpotter in
our communities. If you can give us some insight
on the value of that and if you anticipate that the cost of Shot spotter
will decrease I don't know about decreasing.
We hope as we add more, we can make better deals.
But it's a tremendous piece of technology,
gun detection. We've had cases where when
they discharge a firearm, we're immediately responding
to it and we have made some arrests. So as
many more as we can stand up as fund and allow.
But again, you look at different cities,
it's not just the city government responsibility.
Everybody has to kick in corporations so we
can stand up more, but it's something that's needed and wanted by
the chief and our men and women in uniform.
So it's something I hope we can find more. But also
the corporations and private entities step up and assist
us with. That. And then I wanted to talk about
the rollout of the outward facing cameras.
If we can eventually come back to maybe
public safety once that 90 day period is
up, to talk about those places that have
installed those cameras or the ones that have not.
What we need to do to make sure that we are enforcing that ordinance.
One of the biggest complaints we have in our district is the
nuisance that is created at a lot of those convenience stores.
And when you let that petty crime go on, it leads to bigger
crime. So I think we are headed in the right direction with those ordinances.
And we appreciate all that you and your entire
team is doing to keep us all safe in the city of Houston. Thank you.
Council Member we're very intentional on holding those convenience
stores, bars, and anybody, any,
established accountable for helping us fight crime.
Council member. Leticia plummer. Thank you so much. Mayor Person.
Thank you, Chief. Good morning. Good morning. Two questions.
What is the retention rate of our cadets?
Do they stay with the force? Have we found that?
You know, I had some let me see
if I had some numbers. When did they graduate?
I forgot where I was on my page. I looked at it.
Be specific. When they graduate. Yes. Let me get
you a percentage. I know we have it somewhere here, but we'll
get that to you. Absolutely. Okay, wonderful. Thank you. I would like to know that
you're looking at graduation rate. How long? Stay on
the course. Okay, I got you. What's the retention rate of our graduates?
Because we're paying for them to be trained. Right. Got you. Okay. And then what
would that look like in terms of increasing that number, whatever that is?
We can talk offline on that. The other question is, you mentioned the
Biden administration. Congratulations on meeting with the President.
Thank you. Just honestly, I hear that we
can put thousands of officers on the ground, but if we don't get forensics funded
properly, it leads to two issues. Right. The backlog
is going to continue to increase, and then people are going to be falsely accused
for issues. Yes. So my question to you is maybe this is a not right
now question, but I would love to see our forensics department
get the money that they need. I think they need I think they're short,
like, $9 million to fill that, to get that backlog
handled. And also training
and funding going toward
our officers that collect the data,
specimens, et cetera, on the ground so
we can make sure whatever is collected is collected properly. Yes. And our
officers are going to need training and all that they need to do
to that do that well. So those are two things I would love to see
line items for. Yes. Okay.
Thank you. Council Member Carolyn Evan Shabaz.
Thank you, Mayor Pro tim and I believe last year,
council Member Pollard gave 50,000,
I think, to the forensics unit. And I would like to,
like they say, follow that cab. I'd like to do that as well
from my council district service funds. And I urge other council
members to look at that as well, because we're
going to have to get these cases, get the information
that is given to us examined in order to move
through the court system. And so I would like to say
that and challenge my colleagues to do the same.
Thank you. Council member Tasha
Jackson. Thank you.
Hey, Chief. How are you? Good morning, Council. So I have three
questions. So what is HBB's clearance rate for
violent crime last year? And what is the
clearance rate for crime overall? And then lastly,
constituents have reached out about the cadet classes
and just want to know what is HBD doing to recruits
from within the neighborhoods? There's a complaint
that concern that the officers that's patrolling
the neighborhoods do not reflect the
race, the people that they're so they want to see more black officers in
the district. What are we doing to recruit the
black officer? Let me start with the clearance rates.
I went over the homicide. I'll have to get back with you, and we'll get
some time in the day. On the other clearance rates for
violent crimes. In terms of pacifically
African American officers, the first thing I want to
do is make sure that we're recruiting good officers. I want to look
at that heart. But I understand when you have
officers from the community who are committed, who knows the
community, it helps. So we are doing
everything we can to increase the diversity
in our agency. But I also do
not, and I say this with a lot of respect,
I don't ever want to discount the contributions
of non minority officers with our
agency. And I know that you're not accident or saying that, but I
want to acknowledge their work because they have been in our communities doing
all much work for 25,
35 years without any complaints and
retired honorably. So I do want to acknowledge that.
But at the same time, what are we doing to increase minorities?
We're going out to where they are, the universities.
Let me stop. Keep going. Okay,
universities. Some of the radio stations,
hip hop radio stations,
wherever they are, we instituted not
the word study, but the
life program. What is it, life history,
where you get an individual and I'll get this
quick example. We had at first,
you had to have so many college hours or you had to be honorably discharged
from the military. What about the young man and young lady that worked
at Ups or any other job for five years and is a great
individual? And we say in our agency, well,
you don't have a college, you don't have a military, we don't want you.
We did away with that. Okay? So we're looking at other
ways that we can recruit not only minorities, but anybody
to increase that pool. And we'll continue to do that. But I
need help from council members and everybody else in our
community. It's just not the job of the police department.
I need you all to advocate for us, and I know you all do,
but all citizens. It is a great career, and I know
people don't think that sometimes because they listen to
the negative, but this is an honorable profession, and we'll
continue to do whatever we can increase those numbers.
All right, so before we go to
second round of questions from council members, I have a couple of questions,
and it's related to some of the comments you made,
specifically backlog and more demand on the
Houston Forensic Science Center.
Over the past couple of years, we've become very aware of a significant
backlog in forensic lab testing, mostly due to
COVID, mostly due to a halt in court operations,
increase in homicides. We have job openings that
we can't fill. What can we do? Because it
seems as though the testing that we're doing today won't be available
for three years. So to council Member Plummer's point and to council member
Evan Shabbaz's point, if we arrest someone today
for a homicide or whatever, do some testing,
it's not for three years that this person actually goes
to court. Thus we're seeing a lot of bad
people going back on the streets. So when people talk about
violence, I will point to the
courts, the judicial system in the city of Houston and Harris County,
but we also have to look at the Houston Forensics Science
Lab. So what can we do to
make sure that we get these bad guys to trial quicker
with forensic evidence and get them off the streets?
Merrick pro TEM. I don't want to speak for them, but whatever we
do, we need to make sure that we're working together to
make sure that there's properly staffing
and funding of that. I don't know all the operations
over there, but just as we
support the police officers, we got to support all the
departments, and they need some help over there.
And again, I think the mayor, when it's bought to
him and laid out, he's going to make the
right decision, and I'm sure that city council will support it.
So as a non police guy, I'm going to draw a parallel between
forensic testing backlog and number of
criminals that are on the streets. So until we get
part a solved, we're going to constantly see more bad guys on
the streets. So I'll point to something. We gave you a
million dollars in ARPA funds for buyback guns.
Has that program been successful? How many guns have we
bought back? And specifically, how many dollars have we spent on that
buyback program? We're still standing it up. It was
a lot dealing with it. You know, right now we're
running all of our guns through the knob and system.
So I want to do that. But in a gun
buyback program, you can't get any identification
from the people. What I understand, but I still want to
run those guns, so it's a bit
complicated, and I got
ms. Cloud is not here with our community affairs.
She's coordinating that with us. But we'll
do whatever we can with that. Okay. Thank you, council Member Abby Cayman.
Thank you, Chief. I ask every
department this, and I know that in the appendix, you have a list
here. HPD is
doing an extraordinary job with very
tough circumstances. The unmet needs of the department.
I'd like you to share a little bit about that.
Again, we have a certain amount in the budget. There are
constraints. What are the needs? I'm looking at
this list. A lot of it has to do with technology and
not in the list. I talk about it all the time. I'm like the broken
record about it. But CAD. RMS relies on CAD.
Real time crime center has to do with CAD. So all
of these can you talk about those costs, any additional needs,
including facility needs for
our divisions? Because those buildings are like the
rest of the city right now in terms of struggling. We're in a city of
a huge city. You look at our square miles. The first
need, we have an aging fleet.
If we get anything additional or extra
money, almost 50% of our
fleet is past the lifespan, and that's 100,005 years
for marked 120,000 miles and
seven years for unmarked. Almost 50% of our vehicles
are over. I was at the gas pumps before
I went to DC. And there was a young female officer,
and I had to apologize to her, and she drove up in that car
to put gas in there. I know we're doing the best that
we can do, but we have to do better. As far as
a real time crime center, we do have through
the Tag Center, they have pledged to
fund some of the additions we need to
make it a true real time crime center.
We're still waiting for that money to come down. Hopefully they'll
prove it and we'll move forward on that.
But I would say, number one, the need
for better vehicles and newer vehicles, that is
a must. We're not in a city that's very small
and you can do a lot of foot patrol. Even though I would love I
love foot patrol. I love neighborhood policing. But the fact of the
matter is, you move around in vehicles in Houston, and we need
to keep up with these criminals. And the only way we're going to be able
to do that is put money and funds as much as we can
into the fleet and really
quickly. In addition to Vice Mayor pro TEM's request on follow up
on the new camera ordinance, I'd love to get
an update from you all on the ATF partnership. We keep
talking about violent crime, but it's guns.
Yes, it is. We'll get it. Thank you.
Council Member Sally Alcorn. Thank you, Chair.
There was about a million for increase in
temporary personnel services in the Chiefs command. Is that for
a specific project or ePROs? ePROs.
That's what the okay, got it.
And then I just want to point out and you noticed you had it in
the adjustments. This was a $2 million over budgeting
of health benefits. That comes back to the department.
Correct. Like last year, there was no so it was originally
anticipated that there would be more staffing
and that would actually adjust for
the health benefits. And so the health benefits was
reduced by the finance. Got it. One more thing. And on recruiting,
I like the changes you made, the Ups example and all. And also,
you guys spent over a million dollars, which is a really good thing. On tuition
reimbursement, that should be another big recruiting thing.
Any kind of incentive. I really want us to look at that as
a team. It's really important.
But even front end incentives.
At the meeting in DC, you asked about a councilwoman.
That's what I think has been working for other agencies,
and it may work for us, but also to
help with some of the debt. Now, the challenge is when
individuals come in and we give them front end incentives and
they leave, and we can say, well, hey, we require you to
stay three years or five years, but when they leave, who's collecting the
money? So then that's the challenge that some
of the other chiefs had as well. So just want to bring that up
so we have no other council members in queue. I'll ask the last questions.
It really upsets me when I turn on the media and I hear comments
like the murder capital of the world, and then your comment about homicides
moving from 70% to 70. I had some visitors in town
from my hometown of New Orleans, and they were talking about crime,
murder rates, things like that. And my explanation was
we have a significant problem with domestic
violence. The other day I read a report where
a lady approached a man with a gun. Man took it from her and shot
her. I don't know anyone in the world
who can stop something like that. Whether you have a police force
with 2 million people or a police force with one,
it seems to me like domestic violence shootings,
and I'll call them homicides, are happening each and every day.
So I think I understand your statistics on 70 to seven,
because every time I look at the TV, the murders
are related to domestic violence. So can you lend a little
color to that? As far as the homicide rate? Domestic violence has
ever anything we can domestic violence is one
category that's driving our homicide up. But there
has to be education. There has to be intervention and intervention
into it. And what I mean by that, we have to make
sure with our Dart program and I'm so proud of
that when we have an advocate in the car
with the police officer, once you go to that scene
and somebody is assaulted, they still alive.
It's a vicious cycle that's going to get worse. If we can
lend in what we do, those resources
to that victim or that complainant right away,
get them out of that situation,
that's the way that we save lives.
But it is frustrating to police officers when we're judged.
I don't know how you can prevent it when it's behind walls,
but we can't forget about them. We have to
do everything we can as a society to make sure that we're addressing
it. And we are, but it is frustrating. It's also frustrating
when people turn and they push
their own narrative. What's the narrative now? How many
people you talk and you hear talking about the dramatic
drop in homicide rate? Okay, now we
know summer is here and we know what to expect during the
summer. But we're rolling up and we're going to meet the challenge. And I don't
take all the credit for homicides. I said we have some good investigators
and good police work, but it is truly something that
this community and everybody has to partner up with us to
make the city safer. But we're on the right track. And I
thank you all again for all your support. Thank you. Council member Abby Cayman,
I appreciate that you brought up domestic violence in chief. I'm going to assume that
the over $4 million in ARPA funds that are going towards
Dart, dart forensic nurses is helping. And again,
hats off to Dart. Some of the most dangerous situations
that they're responding to. But mayor pro TEM to your point in
terms of preventative action, again, the majority of domestic violence
homicides are with a firearm and we have no red flag
laws the courts aren't able even to enforce right now. So if
there's a record of someone perpetrating or is
a domestic abuser, I'm assuming, chief,
you all can't remove those firearms from that situation.
Yeah, we still can move when
there's evidence of violence, you can temporarily move those firearms and
we do do it, but I don't dab into the
politics too much. But I do want to say this lawmakers,
and we talked about this in DC. Around the nation, I don't care if you're
local, you state or you're federal,
everybody needs to be real careful as we move
through the pandemic and violent crimes. Be careful what you
vote for, be careful what you write in law, okay? When there's
a backlog, we need to do the
best that we can do and not point fingers at
reducing the guns on the street, especially in the wrong hands
of individuals who commit violence after violence.
Now everybody's smart in here and we read through the lines,
but everybody needs to do their part.
I just encourage friends and
family and anybody. We need to do our part and be smart about
gun violence. We really do.
Council member Tiffany Thomas. Thank you. Mayor Pro tim
raised a really good point about the domestic violence, but I can't help to
think about active shooter issues happening,
and I know there was some in north Harris County. Buffalo is
the latest one. And so the investment in
domestic violence is significant. But when we're talking about active shooter
and making sure your division is ready because I have to have conversations
with my father about going to grocery stores right, and transitioning
that because of what could possibly be. We're a huge city and I don't see
that in terms of your division around active shooter and that training.
But do you need additional resources for your men and women in order
to always use additional resources?
Sure. Active shooting, anything else? But Councilwoman, you bring
up a valid point. We do need the world that we're living in
today. We all need to be ready for whatever comes.
And an active shooting is a problem, and I
hope I'm wrong, but I think it's going to get worse before it gets
better. And we all have to look out for one another to the public.
Be aware of your surroundings. I want us to keep going where we're
going and take care of one another, but be aware of your surroundings.
We'll continue with our active shooting training that
Steven Daniels does and some other individuals,
and we need to increase that because you have to be
in a mindset and if you don't think about it before it happens,
you're going to freeze. So we got to get in the mindset and we
have to train our officers to respond quickly and effectively. But also
citizens need to know what to do. The first
few seconds of an active shooter,
the first few minutes, if you can survive that,
if you can do the right thing and wait for
the police arrive, once we arrive, we handle it pretty
quickly. So we all need to, as a community, be aware of it
and train up.
Vice mayor pro TEM martha kestex tatum. Thank you,
chair. I really wanted to just amplify some
of the performance measures that
you have in your book and the external
citizen complaints with the expected
performance measures of a reduction of 2%.
I like the trend in that
specific category, especially because now we
have more ways for people to report their complaints.
And the fact that we have opened that up with
the addition of Ms. Okafor's office and the other
opportunities that people have to actually express their concerns
and that we're trending downward, I think it speaks volumes for
our city and for our police department. And then
on the accomplishments that we completed,
78 of 104 of the
mayor's task Force on Policing Reform recommendations.
I don't think we tout that enough. When that was happening,
we had residents in the city of Houston asking
for these items and we completed 78 of 104
of those recommendations. And as a city and a police
department, I think this speaks volumes for our residents
to know that we hear them and we want to make sure that we
are serving them to the best of our capabilities.
And so I wanted to say thank you to all of our HPD officers
and everyone that served on that task force, to the council
members and to the entire city of Houston, because public safety
is one of the most important things that will take place in our city.
And I think we are leading the nation, hence your
visit to the White House and setting
a real standard as we deal with tough issues in
this country. Thank you so much for bringing that up. That was in the talking
points and I was trying to save time, but I'm so proud
of that and we are all proud of that.
I want to say this too, right quick, if I can.
When I was up in DC.
President Biden's administration. Several members spoke of
our one Safe Houston plan. They said that it was one of the
best that they have seen because we're actually bringing people together and fighting
crime, violence, disruption programs,
dealing with mental illness, more funding for that,
working with domestic violence. But they were very excited about
the way that we are bringing people together, building trust,
working on issues that are symptoms
of violent crime. I'm really proud
and excited about it. And it's not a police thing, it's a community
thing. And that's huge here. And it starts with
council, it starts with our great mayor. And I
was very proud and I am proud about it. Thanks for allowing me to say
that. Thank you, Chief. And we have a number of public speakers that are
going to come before us in a minute. But before we let you go
back to the streets, I applaud
your decision. I'm not sure if who made it on the administrative team,
but to go from six cadet classes to five, but to staff them
with more individuals, to get them on the streets more rapidly,
I think that was a brilliant move and I'm glad to support it.
In the day of defunding police, I'm proud to say that
we add money to your budget, but we can reallocate the amount of money
in there to certain departments, like you mentioned, with the mental health component.
So a lot of those things that we're doing today are very creative
and I applaud you and your staff for doing those types of things.
The one thing that always bothers me, and this is my 9th
Police Department budget process, I always ask
this question, how many of your police officers
are retirement eligible today?
Percentage wise? Just a guess. About 27%?
27%. I look behind you and I see some great individuals
and I walk the streets every day. And you
all do a phenomenal job. I know I couldn't do it,
so God bless. Thank you for what you do.
Stay safe. And as I always say,
whenever I say I'm the last guy, it comes back to somebody else. So council
member Robert Guy egos. I'll give you the last word. Thank you, Mayor Protein.
Thank you, Chief, for the presentation. In regards to
the budget, in regards to recruiting, does HPD
reach out to the High School of Law Enforcement working
some kind of I know, like you stated, that right now you're
required some college degree or some college credits. Yes,
and what have you. So are you all partnering with
the High School of Law Enforcement? Not only that high school, other high schools.
With our youth programs. I forgot to mention that I'm
glad you brought up youth programs and I'm stepping outside,
but it's very important youth and going into this
summer, please, whatever we do with Parks and Rec,
get those pools open, hire more lifeguards
and get some basketball goes up. So we have to do that.
To answer your question, absolutely. And that's a part of
our recruiting. With our Explorer program, we start working with those young
men and young women at a young age,
as early as the 9th grade, getting them acclimated and
hoping that they join our agency later. Well,
that's good to know. And I appreciate also
you mentioning regarding keeping
or us being aware of what's out there in regards to I
know what happened this past weekend in Buffalo and what happened in El Paso
a couple of years ago. I know that
we received calls from constituents. A couple of weeks ago,
there was a neo Nazi group that was putting baggies out in people's
driveways promoting neo Nazism.
And of course, we asked them to call HPD.
So I don't know if that's are you getting other calls
throughout the city as well? We take those hate
crimes and crimes of bias really seriously.
I hadn't seen the uptick, but I'll get you some stats
just to make sure. But it's a call to our entire community
to look after one another, and we really need to stamp out that hate
at the earliest moment. We can just stop
it and stamp it out. And there's some responsibility to close
friends and family members as well. When you see it, get your
loved ones some help.
Great. Thank you. Once again, thank you for what
you do each and every day. Thank you to my friends in HPOU
and as I heard two weeks ago, officers dismissed.
We'll now go to public speakers. Mayor Pro. Tim,
before we leave, I wanted to just reiterate that for the gun buyback
program, it's actually starting July 30, so I think that one
was just determined this morning. So I wanted to. Okay, so it doesn't
start until July. July. July. Got it.
Thanks. God bless.
First public speaker is Fabiola Jimenez.
Fabiola Jimenez. Going once, going twice.
Mr. Jason. Oliver.
Thank have handouts
today.
Sorry, I wasn't trying to put you to work, Councilmember Jackson. I wasn't expecting everybody
to run out during public comment.
And we're going to hold everybody to 1 minute, as instructions stated,
because we have a meeting that starts in just a little while and we have
to transition. All right, I'll go quick. So this handout
shows items that are consistently higher in general fund spending than actuals
and therefore good candidates free allocation to a department like
housing. I know council member Catholic Tatum is gone, but she mentioned the complaint
process. If you go on HPD's website right now, please tell
me if you see an easier process for filing a complaint. It hasn't changed
on their website. It still asks for your Social Security number in a city like
Houston. According to HPD stats and public safety
presentations, violent crime and crime overall was down year to date
before one Safe Houston was announced. I'm concerned that the public is being misled
about things like that. Also, according to the Texas Sandra
Bland Act racial profiling data for 2021,
HPD is a state leader in violent traffic stops.
We have only 3% of stops in Texas, but 44%
of violent stops statewide. That averages out to five violent
stops per day, with three of them targeting black people each
day. With these terrible statistics and the clear danger posed both
to officers and residents by these hundreds of thousands
of stops, how much are we paying for this traffic enforcement?
Thank you. And I'm assuming this is referring to what
I would call a sort of a surplus. Look ahead.
Exactly. Okay. Every year, you'll notice within the
Mo for monthly financial reports, when we get to the end of the year,
we have a large differential between what we gave
departments and what they've actually spent. All that money rolls into our
fund balance. That's why we maintain a healthy fund balance. This year,
it's projected to be 13 five based on exactly
this information that you gave us. So when the departments
don't spend the money that's been allocated by council, it rolls into fund
balance, and we're at 13.5%, and the obligated
fund balance is 7.5%. So we're doubling that for the rainy day.
But we want departments to spend that money. Right. So if we reallocate
these overages, right? Correct. We get hundreds of thousands,
but millions of dollars. Right. Then we get to use those monies for buyback
programs or forensic we heard the problem with forensic science lab. Maybe we
use some of that for parks
or parks, whatever. You're exactly right. Right. So I just want to
say that these are clear candidates for hundreds of thousands of
dollars of potential reallocation from years of consistent over budgeting
for these items. Council. Member Alcorn, some of the drainage
improvements that we talked about in District B. Absolutely.
District e. Stop. A blanding.
Thank you. Question comes from a robin. Sorry, I'm back in. Okay. I just
wanted to point out, I did ask I did notice that $1.4 million increase
in temporary personnel services, that is for hiring the retired officers.
So that looks like your biggest item on there. I think these
are adjustments from where we end up and where we're budgeting next
year, correct? Yes, sir. Ma'am. Thank you. Thank you.
Mr. Oliver saba blandy did
bring your daughter today. Listener I know she had tar testing.
How many people with a documented history of mental health challenges did
HPD arrest in 2000 and 22,021? How many calls received
by emergency dispatch regarding a mental health crisis were responded to with
armed police officers in 2000 and 22,021? How many of
those were part of a Cert team? How many of those were individual officers without
the support of a trained mental health professional? How many calls received by emergency
dispatch regarding a mental health crises were responded to with an unarmed
response through MCOT in 2000 and 22,021? I heard it would only
cost 23 million to expand Heart Holistic Assistance Response Team to cover
all of Harris County. Harris county currently has invested 1.2 million
for a pilot program. How would it relieve HPD officers to have such a
program expanded into Houston? Would the city of Houston consider expanding
the Heart pilot into Houston? To quote precinct
to Commissioner Adrian Garcia, heart is a historic investment
in public safety, and I'm excited to see this cutting edge program be launched
soon. As a longtime member of law enforcement who has seen firsthand
what's happening in some communities, I know that having the right people respond
to a scene can make all the difference between a positive or tragic outcome.
Okay, thank you for your comments. What I would do is I would send that
exact list and give it to your council member, and let's
make sure that we have that answered, and we'll post that on SharePoint for
every council member. So thank you for your interest.
Council Member Sally Alcorn. Thank you, Chair. And thank you
to the public speakers. I think this is hard. You've sat through a long meeting,
and you're really trying to spit it all out. I will have a form up
on my website, hopefully by the end of the day. I send it out via
email where you can submit questions easily.
We want to make sure we track all that too fast to write down.
But thank you very much for your participation, and we do respect
the fact that you have questions that you want answered. Thank you.
And thank you for that notice. And also
have council members questions that were asked during this session and other
sessions posted to SharePoint as well. And we'll make sure that we get
those included for the public mr.
Christopher Rivera.
Hello, Nick. I'm glad some
council members mentioned the performance measures measurements.
My question is, why should the police department receive an additional $32 million
when they continue to fail and in some instances barely meet the department's
2022 performance measurement goals? For example, the police set
a response time goal of 75%. The police estimate they will
only reach that goal by 55% this year,
failing to meet that goal by 20% next year, the police
will be lowering that goal to 65% to accommodate the police slow response.
Here's an instance when police barely reached their goal. The police department priority
was to have an average response time of four to six minutes. The police estimate
that the average response time is five minutes and 54 seconds. The previous
year's response time was slightly faster. Why should we continue invest
in systems that fail us when there is so much need for housing,
parks and services that benefit the community and doesn't criminalize
us? I would like a response.
Thank you, Mr. Rivera. No response.
There are no council members in queue.
Lauren Johnson,
am I closing us out today? So just
to be fair, I heard you saying that we should submit
our questions to the council, and we'll do that, but also
we couldn't have done that before because the presentations hadn't been
made. I know the slides were available, but also the process has been
different in previous days, so that wasn't possible.
I was interested in hearing about the site and release program. I'd like to
know a little more about how many times that has been used
in 2000 and 22,021, and also if there
are plans to expand it and find out where the problems
exist in that program. Because I think it should
be being used more and we haven't been seeing it live up to its full
potential. So I think it's important to identify what's going
on with that and how we can improve that program. That's it.
Thank you, Ms. Johnson. Thanks, Mr Peter Stout.
Good afternoon, you all. Dr. Peter Stout, head nerd of the crime lab.
I mostly showed up just to answer any questions. I figured there
probably would be some questions with HPD as we
are inextricably linked to what HPD does. They depend
on our results for their investigative
investigations. The courts depend on our results for prosecutions.
And if there are questions I can answer for you now about
where we're at, I know there was one question, I forget who asked
it, about pages 456 and 457
are fund 20 213. That was the transitionary fund
for the LGC when we started as the LGC. So right now it's
got three employees left in it. That's why that
is only about 300,000. If you look for the rest of what our budget is,
is on page 233. There's one note in there of the 28
and a half million, and that is really the discussion of the difference between
that and what my board passed and the differences
of what that will mean for us, of what we can do in the coming
couple of years. But if there are questions, I'm happy. Yes. Council member. Leticia plummer.
Thank you so much. And thank you, Dr. Staff, for everything that you do with
your whole entire team. Can you explain a little bit? I know there's a
tell me exactly how much you're looking to need
in terms of increase of your budget and then just a very quick synopsis of
what those those are going to be used for. Certainly what my board passed was
34.4 million.
That includes 2.6 million for wage
adjustments. We are getting our heads handed to us in retention and recruiting.
There's about a million in there to expand the crime scene
unit. There is about
500,000 in there. And we basically walk down the
places that we are the most concerned. Crime scene firearms next.
After that is toxicology Layton prints.
And the balance of that, this is about a $5.9
million difference from this year's budget into next year.
So it's between staffing and then trying to stabilize the growth
of the backlogs that we're seeing.
Another question, and if you receive that money, do you believe that we could decrease
the backlog that we have currently? I don't think so.
Okay. And this is part of the concern that I have.
We have had backlogs grow somewhere between
twice to about five fold, depending on which discipline you're looking
at. The difficulty for us is we are disproportionately affected
by homicide in particular, creates a lot of evidence.
The evidence that it creates goes to our most expensive disciplines. So it's
really disproportionate in the impact that it has on the laboratory.
It is very long arc for us, training examiners
finding equipment. So really, if I were to try and eliminate
the backlog, that would probably take something more in the neighborhood of
45 million. Even if that number were realistic, I couldn't
spend it. I can't find the people, I can't find the equipment in this next
year. So the 34 is designed to work
with what we've got and try and stabilize the growth of the backlogs.
We have 200 amazing people. I have full confidence
they will probably exceed expectations. But so that you have an
understanding of the expectations of what that's designed for, it is to stabilize backlogs,
not reduce anything. Council member
Abbey Cayman. Thank you, Dr Stout.
Just so we're clear, when we talk about evidence
backlogs, that's distinct from the current court backlog.
Correct. Do you want to expand upon that a little bit? Oh,
boy. Yeah. So a crime laboratory gets to
be sandwiched between law enforcement doing
investigations and we do evidence processing as
part of investigations. And as law enforcement builds a case,
then law enforcement hands that case over to prosecutors
to develop the case for prosecution. At that point,
there is a whole nother suite of requests we often get that come from prosecution.
So for us, we've got the increase in particularly
homicide over the last couple of years that sandwiched us from that side
now with the absolutely mind boggling backlog in the courts
as that is picking back up the pressure from
that to support past results that we've done in court
goes up. And the request from prosecutors who are now starting to deal
with cases goes up. So right now my folks are testifying on violent crime
cases typically from about 2017, 2018 as
the courts catch up to where we're at. This is part of my concern is
somewhere in about the next six to twelve months we start to become the
backlog and the bottleneck because the courts are then
going to start waiting on us for results on cases when they get there.
Right now we're not just to be clear as it stands today,
and I appreciate it always helps right when we have people saying,
hey, in about six months or a year we're going to have a challenge and
we need to be looking at that now. So I appreciate that very much.
And right now the court
backlog is not hinging on
the incredible work that the Forensic Science Center is doing.
The DA's office is not hinged on that
either. No, that's not where at right now. You can see the
arc of this. I joke explaining our work
is a little bit more like explaining orbital dynamics than it is like driving a
car. Because what we do now for us impacts where we're at in
about two years. And my concern is even
if you back the truckload of money over on me in two years,
I can't do much with it for another two years. Understood,
but I really appreciate the clarification. Thank you.
So a follow up. So your backlog is
related to people and equipment. Correct. Okay. So you have
a homicide today looking at a presentation that
you had given ways back. We won't get
to the evidence because of the backlog that we have for three years.
And if that employee who's doing the evidence collection
and the data leaves, the clock starts over again.
So that employee goes back to day one and that three years
was wasted. Yeah. This is a consistent
problem for us and really for every laboratory in the state as we
have employees that leave and this is part of the cost to me for employees,
we figure. And I was just at the meeting of American Society
Crime Laboratory directors a couple of weeks ago.
Most labs, it's somewhere between 300,000 and $500,000
to train a new analyst just out of the box,
somewhere between about a year to three years before they're productive in
the laboratory. If they leave in the court,
unless we can get that person to come back and testify about that,
the evidence becomes hearsay. So most prosecutors will want
and pressure us to rework the case with somebody that's actually currently
employed. So you can almost take when an employee leaves, you can
take the work that they've done for about the last three to five years and
throw it out the way backlog. Absolutely. So what's the solution?
We have to stay ahead of the curve.
And this is why, to Council Member Cayman's point right
now, we're not the problem. I am desperately trying
to not be the problem about two years from now, because we
have to try and stay ahead of the arc of this, knowing all of these
challenges that we have to get equipment in to validate things to train employees
so that two years from now, we aren't the headline.
So I would invite Chair Cayman
to bring this up in one of your public safety. Because when I started reviewing
the material for today's presentation, I went back and looked at
the position that if somebody leaves, then you start the clock all over
again, and you just wasted three years. And that person sits in jail for six
years instead of three until the trial comes. So I'd love to
dig into this a little bit more when we have more time.
Those conversations and the planning for that we're speaking,
those are conversations that we're currently having right now. Okay, great.
Thank you. No other council members in queue. Thank you, Doctor. Thank you very much.
I appreciate your support. Yes. Thanks, Dr. Sal. Appreciate what you
do. Joe Grochell followed
by Melissa Martinez and Aris Brown.
So we are spending $8 million on community affairs.
This seems like a very expensive duplication of
city services, especially neighborhoods,
which could be beneficial for all the other departments we've been
hearing from. Would council members consider
and support consolidation?
And then my other question is in
what the police said in his objectives is how
do you measure reduce fear?
I would like him to like you all to figure that out. How do you
measure reduce fear? If you
write those questions I'm sure you have in your notes, submit it to your council
member. We will enter that and we will get the answers within 48 hours.
Thank you, and thanks again for coming. You're welcome. Melissa Martinez.
Hi.
I have a couple of questions, such as how many unhoused
students and how many the in house and
students have been arrested by HPD in 2000 and 22,021?
Because I know that a lot of council members have previously
discussed about all these cases of domestic abuse
and all these other abusive, very violent
situations. And I wanted to follow up with another question,
because after listening to other departments that were brought up here today
on how some, even you yourself, praise how
much they could do while being underfunded within
their own limited, low budgets. And I wanted to ask if
there could be a possibility with all these issues of
being at the intersections and facing these violences that they
do need to be funded, such as housing in public
libraries, the public recreations. As myself,
I am a survivor of domestic abuse. And those are those
things yes, ma'am. That helped me. Yes, ma'am.
So it comes down to it's an easy equation.
It's revenue versus expenses.
Revenue is capped. We receive revenue
from basically two sources property taxes
and sales taxes. Our sales tax projections look
pretty good. Unfortunately, with inflation taking place, the cost of goods
are going up. Thus our sales tax revenue has gone up. This will
be the 8th year out of the past nine years that
we've had a tax rate decrease.
And the tax rate is a function well, your taxes on your
homestead is a function of two variables.
The tax rate that we have times your value
of your home. That's the revenue we receive on the
property tax. So we're capped by the
state of Texas so that every year we have to reduce
our tax rate, which means we don't get the ability
to spend the money that is coming in via property
taxes because it is capped, as is every major
city in the state of Texas. However, the cap we're
under is different than the cap. Dallas is under,
san Antonio is under, and Austin is under
because they're on a lesser cap. So when you look
at property taxes, the tax rate has gone down eight of the last
nine years. When you look at sales tax revenue,
we've had some tough times during COVID but the projections look
better. At the same time, our personnel costs
are increasing. Police 4%
salary increase come July 1 fire 6%
salary increase come July 1 city Employees and
municipal Employees 3% July
1 and you saw in the information we were presented that 65%
of our overall budget on the expense side is due to
personnel. So when you have those equations,
it's a no win situation unless
you go out and tell people in the city of Houston, do you want your
taxes to increase?
Every year I do this and I announce it to fellow council members. I look
at my tax bill and I share it publicly. And in my
tax bill this year that I paid in February, the amount
of dollars that I gave to the city of Houston was 19%
of my overall tax bill.
My school district taxes are 56%.
We had an election on Saturday for a bond referendum that passed
overwhelmingly. But yet, every time
I'm out in public, people look at me and say, your taxes
are way too high in the city of Houston. And I point
back to my school district taxes. Yeah, you get
what you pay for. But I have no children anymore
that are in the K through twelve education and I look
really closely at the dollars that are spent in my particular school district.
So I've rambled way too much. But we have a no win situation
in the city of Houston because of the property tax cap that we're
under and the sales tax revenue projections that
we see coming at us. Because basically, we have those two sources.
And if I ask Joe Q public if they want their taxes increased by
the city, they'll say, not no, but heck no.
Thank you. I wanted to follow up real quick because we got to
get out about all these caps on the taxes. And I
was asking that's why I was directing it towards HBD,
having all these allocations of funds, and that way
that other departments could be invested through those instead
of just hiring these tax caps that you were mentioning.
Yes. Thank you,
Eris Brown. Last but not least
for the day.
Hello, city Council. I just want to say it's particularly heartbreaking
to sit and a lot of people have come from their jobs
and are not able to receive income because they're here,
and not to be able to have their questions answered by the folks who make
the presentations. And so I did want to mention that my
first question is research has shown strategically
and well designed parks can reduce gun violence,
improve safety, and keep residents healthier with the council
see a benefit in allocating some of the resources to the
very clearly underfunded Parks and Recreation Department. But what would
alleviate the work that needs to be done by HPD officers?
We've been talking a lot about prevention,
and a lot of the measures that we've thought about with HPD's presentation have
been reactive. Adding more, doing this. Are we interested in
more preventative measures by funding through parks and recreation
libraries, et cetera? My first question, my second question is
the PFM report. And Chief Finner's comments last year
showed that we've had police officers doing the work that can and should be
done by civilians. I wanted to know if there has been a shift in that
practice at all. If you go to the website, HPD has about 5400
officers and 892 civilians.
I'm interested if we've made any sort of shifts in those past couple
of years.
Thank you for your question. If you look at personnel,
classified versus civilian,
classified was 93%, civilian was 7%
in the 2023 budget. And then the personnel
on we'll get back with you. There's a number of different categories
with that. So if you would post your question to your council member,
we'll make sure that question is answered.
Council Member Ed Pollard. Thank you, Mayor Pro TEM.
And thank you to all the speakers who spent time coming in person to
address your question. One I would like to see the study so I can see
what you're reading. So if you want to send that to our offices, that would
be great. I think there's always ways in
which we can look at preventative measures through either different programs,
after school programs, parks, libraries,
and it would be great if we could have some additional dollars for those
programs. I think from parks,
libraries, airports, police, fire, they're all going
to say, we need more. There's not one department that's going to say
we couldn't perform better if we had more dollars.
And so from our standpoint, we have to make reasonable
decisions regarding where those allocations are.
Every single night you turn on the news, all you hear is issues
with public safety. That is the number one email we get.
That is the number one call we get.
Whenever we go to homeowners associations, people are talking about crime.
They're also talking about trash. They're also talking about a couple of other things,
but they're always talking about crime. So we have to find ways in which
to provide adequate law enforcement and
public safety, but also kind of reimagine it that it's not
always in the same way. So to think
about police officers not always having to serve
in traditional roles, I think Council Member Leticia Plummer,
she brought forth an amendment last year regarding having more
clinicians and technicians and medical professionals. And that's something that
the mayor has put forth in his One Safe Houston plan.
So we are looking at ways in which to not have
the same type of traditional police officers do, the same type
of traditional duties, but it's something that we need to continue to explore
to see how we can make those additional steps.
Right. And thanks for Ms. Brown, for your comments. As we talked about in
their session, we've increased the budget projected to increase the budget
in police. But the way we allocate those dollars are a lot different this year
moving forward versus last year piggybacking police with mental
health problems, the homeless initiative that we have a big situation
with. So to Council Member Pollard's point,
using the dollars a little bit differently moving forward
than we do today, we don't think reimagination. I'm interested in
how we can imagine these things outside of the methods that haven't worked,
like the police department and actually putting them in programs that can work
if we're thinking about reimagination, right? Yes, ma'am. I think
that'd be a difference of opinion and perspective on what may
work and what does not work. And I think those are discussions we need to
continue to have. Absolutely. And I appreciate you making
those comments. And if you could provide the information on that study, I'd love to
read it. Absolutely. Thank you. You're welcome. Yes, ma'am. Thank you. There are no other
public speaking meeting adjourned until tomorrow. We'll pick up budget
meetings at 01:00 with Houston Airport System.